[Music]
so you're not from around here it's hard
to explain
[Music]
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
[Music]
I'm not what you think I am
real arson tell me what's it going to be
like what kind of footage have you seen
well we've saw the teaser trailer that
we released and broke records we of
course have seen the movie many times it
is coming together extremely well she
does it a tremendous job
Sam Jackson is a very different version
of Nick Fury does an amazing job the
entire cast this one is very different
and very exciting what's different about
takes place in the 1990s and while it is
an origin story of our hero it is a very
different type of origin story which
we're excited to unveil to audiences hey
everybody it's Charlie Kevin Feige
talking more about the Captain Marvel
movie how it's a very different type of
origin story you may remember him saying
stuff like that a couple of years ago
saying that they weren't doing
conventional origin stories anymore so
let's break it down there's a new round
of that spider-man ps4 game giveaway or
for the DLC whichever all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
long time ago Kevin Feige said that
they're not doing the old school type of
origin stories and that predates the
introduction of spider-man in the MCU as
well as the Doctor Strange movie even
though I kind of considered Doctor
Strange a conventional origin story
because he gets into an accident we
follow him to the ancient one he trains
gains power defeats the villain
cassellius and Dormammu then returns to
continue on his path to becoming Earth's
sorcerer supreme it's almost exactly
like the path of the original Iron Man
movie or any of the phase 1 Avengers you
get a really jarring intro than a rewind
to show you how you got there then most
of those original phase 1 movies
continued in a fairly linear fashion
from say like the Iron Man mark 1 to the
Mark 3 the big oh crap moment of that
original Iron Man movie wasn't so much
the way they did the origin story it was
actually that big tag at the end where
he just reveals the secret identity like
oh my god is a superhero this revealing
his secret identity because at the same
time that was coming out we were getting
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
and Batman's secret identity is still a
very big deal even in comics today an
Iron Man was just throwing it out there
for the world to see like I am Iron Man
so the reason why Kevin Feige is saying
that after all these Avengers character
origin stories that we've got
this is
to be a very different type of origin
story it's because there's a lot of
false narration and misdirection in the
way they present the character when you
first see her they've changed the way
they tell her origin story just on a
functional level the narrative of the
movie as well as the story itself on a
fundamental level the teaser trailer
that I put at the beginning of this
gives you all the clues you need to tell
you these things and why it is so
different like they even try to lay some
of that dialogue in there I'm not who
you think I am that's very telling
obviously it's a moment in the movie but
it's also a tip-off for us the audience
because most of us will go see the movie
knowing at least some version of her
origin story from the comics even if
you're not a really big comic book fan
you have a vague idea of who her
character is and how she got her powers
so as an audience member you go to see
the movie you see Carol Danvers she
looks human you assume she's human she
grows up on planet earth like a normal
kid would becomes a badass Air Force
pilot has a really edgy personality to
match gets into an accident gets powers
learns to use those powers blows the
crap out of the villains who the trailer
leads you to believe are the scrolls
that's who they're presenting is the
main villain of the movie you probably
detected how they're kind of taking the
mantle as the new go to space space
villains in the Marvel Universe from the
shatori where it starts to get really
different though is it the whole thing
about the origin story that you see in
this trailer is is it from Captain
Marvel Carol Danvers perspective she
believes her origin story to be one
thing when really she's been misled her
entire life so it's one of those
mind-blowing narrative devices where a
really badass hero is on a mission
feeling really righteous about
themselves but they find out that the
reason for their existence is not what
they were told I'm not the person that
everyone namely Jude Law's character and
her parents told her she was so it
becomes this big identity crisis and a
rediscovery of who she is
then a self corrected origin story
midway through the movie like the
characters that you see crashed through
the blockbuster and that funny moment
has an origin story but this version of
Carol Danvers in the classic comic book
red gold costume at the end of the movie
has a whole separate origin story that
we get during the movie after she learns
the truth about who she really is so you
can kind of see
there's a couple moments when she and
the audience at the same time are
supposed to get their minds blown during
the movie new information you get makes
you completely rethink everything you
thought you knew so conventional phase
one Avengers origin stories there's no
real false information he grows up goes
on a life-changing field trip cue avatar
montage gains power learns to use that
power wisely becomes a true superhero so
even though the Captain Marvel you see
at the beginning of the movie already
has her powers in this green crease Star
Force uniform she has not become the
fully actualized version of the
superhero that you see at the end of the
movie as for the story of where she
comes from how she got her powers the
way her powers work I've already done a
video about that last month about the
life of Captain Marvel comic book that's
the prequel story that Marvel's been
dropping in advance of the movie just to
make people understand that MCU Captain
Marvel was gonna be a little bit
different so at a link for that at the
end of this video but essentially her
parents lied to her her whole life about
who she was her mother is this pink skin
Kree one of the best warrior captains in
the Kree Empire sent to earth as a
precursor for galactic conquest she
falls in love with a human man gets
married has a daughter names her Care L
so her real birth name is just the Kree
version of Carol they just call her
Carol so that no one will know that
she's half alien and it can live a
normal life so in the way that Black
Panther was already kind of a badass
before he got the heart-shaped herb and
gained special extra superpowers
Captain Marvel already has a measure of
abilities before she gets into her
accident that unlocks her true cosmic
potential hopefully one of the next
trailers that they drop will reveal some
more information about this we'll break
it down Kevin Feige even says some
really funny stuff about Deadpool and
the x-men characters during phase 4 at
this event that he was at so maybe I'll
do a video for that sometime in the next
couple of days too you may have also
heard them reveal the Kathryn Langford
from 13 reasons why is gonna be in
Avengers 4 as a mystery character so if
there's anything you want me to do a
video for just let me know in the
comments but congratulations to carly
fernandez you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here to watch Kevin Feige reveal a whole
bunch of stuff about avenge
Marvel phase 4 and click here for that
Captain Marvel brand-new origin story
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]